llegamos al momento de revisar toda la
prensa internacional y nos acompaña
Marta Moya Marta bienvenida muy buena
mañana de martes abrimos Entonces esta
revista de prensa Marta con la cobertura
de toda la prensa internacional frente a
la más posible encuentro entre el
presidente chino y su homólogo ruso
Vladimir Putin que está previsto que se
reúnan en la Cumbre de la Organización
de cooperación de Shanghai en Uzbekistán
a finales de esta semana Así Raúl buenos
días el
South china morning post abre el lunes
abre el martes destacando esta reunión
de alto Rango entre el presidente y el
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin que se
reunirán previsiblemente a finales de
esta semana dicen Pues que es la primera
reunión entre ambos desde la pandemia Y
por supuesto desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa dice pues que el viaje de
chillimping empezará el miércoles entre
kazajistán y Uzbekistán y pues
probablemente concluirá el viernes en
ese encuentro en esta organización de
cooperación en Shanghai que hice la
agencia bloomber Marta bloomber destaca
una reunión entre los altos diplomáticos
chinos y rusos el lunes en Beijing y
dice que ambas naciones estarían
dispuestas a construir un orden mundial
más justo y más estable y destaca Pues
que este es como decíamos el primer
encuentro entre ambos presidentes y que
pues que Rusia sea china Perdón se ha
mantenido de perfil un poco durante la
invasión rusa Y que ahora pues aunque no
ha condenado explícitamente al régimen
de Putin tampoco pues sea privado ha
puesto palos en las ruedas
a proporcionar sanciones y dice pues que
las importaciones chinas han sido un
alivio para Putin en este Bueno pues en
estos más de seis meses de la guerra
vamos a ver ahora dos visiones Marta la
estadounidense y la china pero empezamos
con estadounidense con Fox news
pues muy a la derecha en Estados Unidos
también destaca este encuentro entre los
líderes y dice pues que Estados Unidos
tiene que hacer diplomacia que es lo que
ha venido haciendo como para que Rusia o
sea china no tome El ejemplo de Rusia
con la invasión a Ucrania y haga lo
mismo con Taiwán dice que ambas naciones
tienen pocos amigos en occidente y que
son Pues los firmes opositores al poder
el global Times
al contrario un medio muy alineado al
partido comunista chino destaca pues la
sede de este encuentro no de la
Organización de cooperación de Shanghai
y dice pues que no es como la otan y que
la organización de cooperación de
Shanghai no tiene pues estos
no tiene este tintes de protección como
tienen la otan defensivos que será un
encuentro de 15 jefes de estado y que
bueno destaca pues este este entorno en
el que se va a dar la reunión el próximo
15 y 16 de septiembre que por supuesto
la vamos a llevar aquí todas las
incidencias de esta reunión en revista Y
claro que nuestros informativos en
Francia 24 cambiamos de tema ahora Marta
Porque la contra ofensivo ucraniana las
últimas jornadas y el repliegue de todas
las tropas rusas en zonas estratégicas
en el sur y en el noreste del país
también está reflejando en toda la
prensa internacional concretamente el
día de hoy martes en Washington puedes
llevar una columna de opinión en la que
habla de cómo se redefinen no estas
fuerzas entre Putin y selensky así Esa
es un artículo de opinión de David
dignacio es un experto de política
Internacional del Washington post que
dice pues que la contraofensiva
ucraniana hace cambiar un poco la
ecuación de los dos líderes de Vladimir
Putin y de
bolodimirselensky pues es un héroe poco
probable que al final pues
unió a la sociedad ucraniana en torno a
una defensa de su pueblo y planea una
estrategia defensiva pues muy exitosa y
que bueno pues en sus deseos están
liberar a Ucrania pero dice este
artículo de opinión que eso todavía es
un deseo poco realista y que debería
impulsar la vía diplomática aunque los
rusos pues quieran o no estén de acuerdo
con esa opinión porque ahora selensky
pues tiene la sartén por el mango dice
además de Putin Pues que es El perdedor
del último asalto y es el hombre que
nunca pierde entonces pues que él quería
crear una guerra de salón para que los
rusos vieran por la tele como Pues iban
avanzando en Ucrania pero pues que hasta
los más fieles del kremlin ahora
sostienen que esto ha sido una gran
pérdida la contraofensiva ucraniana de
los últimos días bueno Marta gracias por
toda la información